[Musique]
on se fout d'être mal au
11ème encore du camp
non
[Musique]
plus rien à peine
quand
maa
mian appelle
si tu pars avec moi
les gens nous
les lois
si je pars avec toi je
j étais tu sors
si je danger d'un mois
tu l auras tes chers
m
m'accrocherai at war comme le lieu
j'ai
ouah
super
pour leur accueil un hommage
où
on pourra me
désespérément
en fait pour
ce qu'on peut penser
on
se fout de tout
fou
[Musique]
le camp
thomas
rien appel
[Musique]
ap
si tu pars avec moi
[Musique]
même si tu es
tu ne pourras jamais
quand on choisit sa vie
fall a dit
[Musique]
je serais allé thouars contre la terre
entière
ces moqueries
de la folie
[Musique]
juste on veut aller
mais rien à faire
[Musique]
la terre